[Música]
nuevo cruce de acusaciones entre Rusia y
Ucrania en esta oportunidad por cuenta
de un ataque cerca a la planta nuclear
de sapurilla mientras Moscú culpó a kiev
aseguró que el ejército ruso llegó a
cabo un acto terrorista que pone en
peligro la seguridad de Europa
Estados Unidos logró reducir el
desempleo una décima en el mes de julio
lo que técnicamente aleja al país del
fantasma de la recesión los datos de la
oficina de estadísticas laborales
muestran que el pasado mes con la
creación de 528.000 trabajos el
desempleo bajo de 3,6 a 3,5%, llegando a
cifras previas a la pandemia
la policía de nicaragüense acusó a la
Iglesia Católica y al obispo Rolando
Álvarez organizar grupos violentos e
incitarlos a cometer actos de odio esto
tras varios días de represión anunciados
denunciados por Álvarez quien asegura
que no le permiten salir de la diócesis
de matagalpa
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornadas soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Ucrania Moscú
y kiev se culpan el uno al otro por el
bombardeo contra la planta de saporilla
la mayor central nuclear de Europa la
instalación ha sido una fuente de
preocupación desde que Rusia tomó el
control en medio de su invasión a
Ucrania hay temor mundo por las
actividades militares de Moscú que
podrían estar poniendo en peligro la
seguridad de la planta más detalles en
el informe el ataque a la mayor central
nuclear de Europa en sapurilla Ucrania
ha hecho que ambas partes se culpen
mutuamente
hoy los ocupantes crearon otra situación
muy peligrosa para todos en Europa
bombardearon la central nuclear de
saporilla y la han hecho dos veces en un
día Esta es la central nuclear más
grande de nuestro continente y cualquier
bombardeo es un delito flagrante un acto
terrorista Rusia tiene que asumir la
responsabilidad solo por crear una
amenaza para la planta de energía
nuclear como tal
celenski pidió a toda la comunidad
internacional Que sancione a toda la
industria nuclear rusa Mientras tanto
Moscú ha atribuido el ataque a su
enemigo y lo describe como una descarga
de artillería ucraniana las fuerzas
rusas se apoderaron de la planta y de la
ciudad vecina en marzo y según los
servicios de inteligencia británicos sus
intenciones respecto a la planta Siguen
sin estar claras Aunque está bajo
control ruso el funcionamiento diario de
la planta ha quedado en manos de
técnicos ucranianos pero se sospecha que
Rusia utiliza la central nuclear como
una base militar desde la que pueden
disparar con la seguridad de que los
ucranianos no se arriesgarían a devolver
los disparos a un objetivo de este tipo
hace tiempo que se teme que las acciones
rusas puedan provocar una catástrofe
nuclear a gran escala
por supuesto es muy peligroso podría ser
otro Chernobyl o incluso algo peor los
habitantes de la zona no son los únicos
que están preocupados incluso antes del
bombardeo la agencia internacional de
energía atómica llevaba varias semanas
intentando realizar una inspección de la
planta pero la parte ucraniana no está
dispuesta por temor a que esto legitime
la ocupación rusa el director general
del organismo de vigilancia nuclear
Rafael grossi subrayó que probablemente
se estaban violando todos los principios
fundamentales para el funcionamiento
seguro de una central nuclear vamos a
Estados Unidos donde los datos de la
oficina de estadísticas laborales
muestran que en julio se crearon
alrededor de 528.000 puestos de trabajo
reduciendo el desempleo en una décima lo
que aleja al país de las sombra de la
recesión la cifra pasó de 3,6 a 3,5%, Lo
que equivale a 5,7 millones de
desempleados el mes pasado frente a 5,9
millones en junio la robusta cifra
representa un respiro para el gobierno
estadounidense que pese a la contracción
económica en dos trimestres conse
objetivos ha negado reiteradamente una
recesión
hoy recibimos otro informe de empleo
sobresaliente y el mes pasado se
agregaron 528.000 empleos en este país
528.000 trabajos ahora casi hemos
duplicado lo que teníamos casi en 10
millones de empleos desde que asumí el
cargo
Este es el crecimiento laboral más
rápido en la historia hoy también
igualamos la tasa de desempleo más baja
en Estados Unidos en los últimos 50 años
3,5%, Sí
3,5%. hoy hay más personas trabajando en
Estados Unidos que antes del comienzo de
la pandemia De hecho hay más personas
trabajando en Estados Unidos que en
cualquier otro momento de la historia
del país
republicanos y demócratas de Estados
Unidos viven desde hace semanas un nuevo
tira de afloja esta vez con las vidas de
miles de migrantes irregulares en el
centro gobernadores republicanos del Sur
del país como Texas y Arizona en vía
inmigrantes en buses gratis hacia
Washington en una jugada para presionar
al presidente Joe biden y pedirle que
responsabilice de los recién llegados el
viernes por primera vez un bus llegó a
Nueva York más Romero nos cuenta más
llegaron a Nueva York después de 36
horas Viajando en un autobús pagado por
el estado de Texas son migrantes
irregulares y pisan por primera vez la
ciudad con esperanzas José Venezuela
Colombia Panamá Costa Rica Nicaragua
Honduras Guatemala México y Texas
tenemos bueno muchas muchos deseos de
trabajar de trabajar salir adelante
Iniciar una nueva vida una nueva vida
que el Gobernador tejano republicano
greca Bot no quiere que vivan dentro de
su estado
desde abril el político ha pagado buses
para transportar más de 6.200 migrantes
a Washington la capital de Estados
Unidos y en el vecino estado de Arizona
su homólogo dar ejemplo con mil personas
más
es parte de una estrategia para
presionar al presidente joeyden y a los
alcaldes demócratas a quienes acusan de
flexibilizar sus políticas migratorias
sin responsabilizarse de atender a los
migrantes vaiden rechaza hacer su
trabajo así que Texas sigue dando pasos
sin precedentes para asegurar nuestra
frontera Nueva York que es el destino
ideal para estos migrantes pueden
recibir los servicios de los que el
alcalde Adams ha presumido tanto en su
ciudad santuario sin embargo la
bienvenida en estas ciudades no ha sido
tan cálida los servicios sociales están
desbordados y muchos de estos migrantes
terminan durmiendo en la calle o en
albergues
y mientras los migrantes solicitan asilo
y buscan trabajo un proceso que dura
meses y pone a prueba cualquier
Esperanza los republicanos y demócratas
las alcaldías las gobernaciones y el
Gobierno Federal se responsabilizan unos
a otros de este repunte de llegadas
desde octubre Estados Unidos ha detenido
a más de un millón 700 personas en la
frontera con México el récord desde 1960
el presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
anunció que no aceptó la renuncia del
Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres que había
puesto su cargo a disposición del
mandatario a través de Twitter el jefe
de estado señaló que Torres Se
comprometió a seguir trabajando por el
país en caso de haber abandonado el
cargo Torres hubiese sido el cuarto
Primer Ministro que en un año que dejaba
el puesto el Primer Ministro presentó su
renuncia el pasado miércoles por razones
personales
en Nicaragua la policía acusó a la
iglesia católica de incitar a actos de
odio al tiempo que abrió una
investigación la información se conoce
cuando se cumplen dos días de represión
contra el obispo Rolando Álvarez uno de
los más fuertes críticos del gobierno a
quien agentes de policía no le permiten
la salida desde el jueves de la diócesis
de matagalpa según la policía Álvarez y
los altos mandos de la iglesia en el
país están intentando organizar grupos
violentos
la Policía Nacional como autoridad
competente para garantizar la paz y la
Seguridad Ciudadana ha establecido
medidas de protección a la población
para que estos hechos no se vuelvan a
repetir Asimismo ha iniciado un proceso
de investigación con finalidad de
determinar la responsabilidad penal de
las personas involucradas en comisión de
estos actos delictivos de los cuales se
ha informado al ministerio público y al
poder judicial las personas investigadas
se mantendrán en sus casas
el mandatario saliente de Colombia Iván
Duque condecoró a su sucesor Gustavo
Petro quien ASUME la presidencia este
domingo con tres títulos honorarios se
trata de un procedimiento habitual antes
del traspaso del mando y está
constituido por la orden de boyacá la
mayor condecoración de Colombia para
militares y ciudadanos destacados en la
categoría de Gran collar reservada para
jefes de estado también por la orden de
San Carlos y la orden nacional al mérito
el acto ocurrió a Puerta cerrada en la
casa de nariño
en Brasil el aspirante presidencial Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva arremetió contra
el mandatario y también candidato Yair
bolsonaro por ignorar la pandemia de
Kobe 19 que deja más de 600.000 Muertos
en el país pero la prometió a sus
seguidores que su gobierno manejará
mejor los problemas de salud y que si es
elegido se centrará en combatir la
inseguridad alimentaria
[Aplausos]
el actual presidente afrontó la pandemia
de manera criminal y es responsable
directo de las más de 678 mil muertes
por covid
algunas de esas muertes son culpa del
presidente por estar en negación
es todo por el momento en France 24 Les
agradecemos su sintonía volvemos en
breve con más información
[Música]